[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANIEL ALEGRE: Ladies and
gentlemen, Secretary Perez.
Please welcome hm.
[APPLAUSE]
THOMAS PEREZ: Thank you, Daniel.
DANIEL ALEGRE: Thank
you for coming.
THOMAS PEREZ: Buenas tardes.
DANIEL ALEGRE: Beunas tardes.
THOMAS PEREZ: Beunas tardes.
DANIEL ALEGRE: Buffalo
Bills-- I don't
think we're here to
talk about football,
but why your affinity
for the Buffalo Bills?
THOMAS PEREZ: I
grew up in Buffalo.
I'm a Buffalo-minican.
My parents got to Buffalo
because of the similarities
in the weather between
DR and Buffalo.
Actually, they had to leave
the Dominican Republic,
because there was a
pretty bad dictator there,
and my father went into
the US Army, served
as a legal immigrant,
and so when he got out,
he was stationed in
Atlanta, Georgia.
And by then, three of
the five of us were born.
He got a job at the VA
Hospital in Buffalo,
and that's where he moved.
And so my sister and
I were born there.
So I'm the caboose of five,
and they settled there,
and Buffalo is a great town.
We were the Dominican Chamber
of Commerce when I was a kid.
There were three Dominican
families, actually.
Now there are many more.
But at the time, there
were just three families.
DANIEL ALEGRE: And I think a lot
of Hispanics here in the United
States have similar stories.
I grew up in Mexico, and
then we emigrated to Toronto,
and we were one of three
Mexican families in Toronto.
But I remember
watching the news.
The only American news
we would get in Canada
would be the Buffalo
news, and whenever
it would snow an
inch in Toronto,
it would snow 10
feet in Buffalo.
So I felt for the
poor Dominicans
who were freezing out there.
THOMAS PEREZ: It's a
great place to grow up.
DANIEL ALEGRE: If
you don't mind,
I'd like to talk a little bit
about your family background.
You mentioned your family's
from the Dominican Republic.
I believe your grandfather
was involved in politics.
THOMAS PEREZ: Yeah.
DANIEL ALEGRE: Can you talk a
little bit about that story?
THOMAS PEREZ: My grandfather
was in the diplomatic service
there starting in
the early 1920s.
And then when Trujillo came to
power around the early '30s,
he became the ambassador
to the United States.
And then in 1935,
at first, Trujillo
was trained by
the United States,
so when he came to
power, there was a hope
that maybe some of that
training would provide him
with a sense of values.
And it turned out
not to be the case.
So by '35, my
grandfather spoke out.
He was removed from his
job, and then in '37
after the massacre
of the Haitians,
he had already been
removed from his job,
but then he was kind of formally
declared non-grata by Trujillo.
So my family moved
to New York City.
My mom lived most of
her life in the States,
even though she was
born in Santo Domingo.
So it was basically the
height of the Depression,
and my mom was the
second youngest of nine,
and they were in the States.
And that's how our
love for this country
came about, because this country
gave my family opportunity.
And so it was-- they
grew up in Mecca
for most Dominicans
is Washington Heights,
so that's where they grew up.
My father left as
well, because he
was part of sort of
a student movement,
for lack of a better term.
And so he left the
Dominican Republic,
and they met, got married, and
settled ultimately in Buffalo,
as I described.
And so you learn
a lot of lessons
from that, including make sure
the ladder's down for others.
DANIEL ALEGRE: What was
it like being one of three
Dominican families in Buffalo?
Was there a big
Hispanic community,
or was it essentially the
three Dominican families?
THOMAS PEREZ: No, there
was not a large community
at all when I was growing up.
I was actually back
there in Buffalo eight
or nine months ago doing
some work on a weekend,
and I was at a
restaurant at an event,
and it was just remarkable
how the community has grown,
not just the Dominican
community, but the Latino
community.
A lot of Puerto Ricans,
more Dominicans,
and frankly, it's very
affordable to live in Buffalo.
And so you look at places like
Bucks County, Pennsylvania,
which is about maybe three
hours from New York City,
and you see this immense Puerto
Rican and Dominican community.
And basically,
they were folks who
settled in New York, got priced
out of the New York market.
You can have a $14, $15 an
hour job in that community
and own a home and live a
really solid middle class life.
So you see in these communities
that have sprouted up.
Reading, Pennsylvania
is 70% Latino.
I mean it's remarkable how
immigration patterns have
transformed communities,
urban, suburban,
and rural, across the country,
and Buffalo is no different.
So I no longer need my hands.
I need much more than my hands
to count the number of Latino
families in Western New York.
DANIEL ALEGRE: Now it's
obviously not a job description
to be of Hispanic heritage
to be the Secretary of Labor,
but what do you think
your background,
how your family came here
to the United States,
how has that
influenced you in terms
of your thinking about your
job as a Secretary of Labor
with the definition that I
had of Americans' livelihood?
THOMAS PEREZ: Well,
my parents taught
all five of us that to whom
much is given, much is expected.
And so actually, all of
my siblings are doctors,
and I'm the black
sheep of the family.
And I had to promise never to
be a plaintiff's personal injury
lawyer, and I kept that promise.
And what I love about
my job is that it really
is consistent with the
values that I was taught,
which are the values
of making sure
there's a level playing
field for everyone.
And the thing I love about my
job at the Department of Labor
is we help people at scale.
I've worked with so many
different businesses, who
understand that when workers
succeed and businesses succeed,
we all succeed.
I've been very involved in this
conscious capitalism movement,
which is really a movement of
a lot of business leaders, who
understand that when
you have a stakeholder
model of governance--
in other words,
shareholders are best served
when all stakeholders are
well-served.
It's not I either take
care of my workers,
or I take care of
my customer, or I
take care of my shareholder, or
I take care of my supply chain.
You can create a virtuous cycle,
and there are so many employers
who are doing that.
And I spent a lot
of time with them,
and we spent a lot of
time bringing together
people who work to ensure
that workers have a voice,
with employers who understand
that when workers have a voice,
that's good for workers,
good for business,
good for communities.
So it's been a
remarkably fun job.
I feel like I'm getting
an MBA on the job.
DANIEL ALEGRE:
Yeah, that's great.
THOMAS PEREZ: And
that's exciting.
DANIEL ALEGRE: I
think the question
of who is a shareholder
has come up many times
during this election.
Are illegal immigrants
considered a shareholder
in this economy or not?
How do you view that?
How do you view the--
obviously, the discussion
that's happening
during the campaign,
but more specifically,
who do you represent
as Secretary of Labor?
Who are your shareholders?
THOMAS PEREZ: Well,
we enforce a number
of laws that are really at
the heart of what it means
to be a worker in
America and what it means
to be middle class in America.
The Fair Labor Standards
Act, for instance,
was, in the words of FDR, the
second most important piece
of legislation after the
Social Security Act ever
passed to help workers.
And the Fair Labor
Standards Act doesn't say,
you have to help all Americans.
The Fair Labor
Standards Act says,
if you worked eight hours, you
should be paid for eight hours.
At the Civil Rights
Division, where
I was before the
Department of Labor,
we enforced a number of laws.
If you were the victim
of a hate crime,
or if you were the victim of
an act of police misconduct,
it didn't matter what your
citizenship or immigration
status was.
And that's because that
really fundamentally reflects
the values of who
we are as a nation.
And we're having a
serious conversation
right now about whether
e pluribus unum still
has meaning in our country.
I think our diversity is our
greatest strength as a nation.
Our diversity is what has
made us a great nation,
and our immigrants
enrich our nation.
When I was the Maryland
labor secretary,
we commissioned a study to
document the contributions
that foreign-born
Marylanders make.
And foreign-born Marylanders
are more likely in Maryland
to have a college degree
than native-born Marylanders.
And our health profession
in Maryland and frankly
across America would
be in much worse shape,
but for the contributions of
immigrants, who are working
in the health profession.
So I believe that
our immigrant history
is such a remarkable part
of the American fabric.
And this isn't the first
time in our nation's history
that we've had this debate.
Those of you who study the
know-nothing movement, that
was an anti-immigrant,
anti-Catholic movement,
and that movement faded
because of the same reason
that these movements
today will fade.
It's because the collective
power of we came together,
and folks were able to
summon our better angels.
And I'm confident.
I have chronic
optimism, because I
see workers and businesses
and other stakeholders
working together day in and day
out understanding that we all
succeed only when
we all succeed.
DANIEL ALEGRE: Right.
Well, I'm going to continue
asking a few questions,
but we'll leave time
for any questions.
If you feel just impassioned
that you really want
to interrupt and ask a question
now, please lift your hands,
and obviously, we'll
be able to answer.
Just going back again
to your history,
how did you end up in civil
rights and a civil rights
attorney?
What led you to that field?
THOMAS PEREZ: Well, I
wanted to change the world.
I looked around, and
I was looking at,
who are some of the
change agents around?
And they seemed to be a
lot of people involved
in the civil rights space.
And I have a portrait in my
office, a picture of myself
with John Lewis, who's
one of my heroes,
along with another
photo with myself
and Senator Kennedy,
for whom I worked.
And these were
folks who understood
what Hubert Humphrey
once said when
he said that the moral test
of our strength as a nation
is how we treat those in the
dawn of life, our children,
how we treat those in the
twilight of life, our seniors,
and how we treat those
in the shadows of life.
And I've derived
incredible fulfillment
from a career in
which we've been
able to expand opportunity,
and both economic opportunity
an opportunity to participate
in the democratic process.
And we have to fortify
our infrastructure
of economic
opportunity, and we have
to fortify our
infrastructure of democracy.
So I feel-- no disrespect
to Lou Gehrig--
I feel kind of like
the luckiest person
on the face of the
Earth, because I've
had these opportunities both
in local, federal, state
government to help
people at scale.
DANIEL ALEGRE: The National
Hispanic Heritage Month,
I guess, was originally the
National Hispanic Heritage
Week enacted during the
time of Lyndon Johnson,
then got expanded to
a month during Reagan.
When do you think it's going be
the National Hispanic Heritage
Year?
When is that legislation
going to pass?
THOMAS PEREZ: Well, I've
said a number of times,
we need to make every day
Martin Luther King Day.
So I'm always ambivalent
about celebrating months,
but I do think it's
great to call attention
to the remarkable
contributions of.
Latinos I'm going to be
hosting an event this week
at the Department of
Labor very similar to this
with the President of
the United Farm Workers,
Arturo Rodriguez, whose
father-in-law was Cesar Chavez.
And so we're using that as
an opportunity to talk about
where we've been, where we've
come, and where we need to go.
And I think these moments
are good reflections
and to look at the remarkable
contributions of Latinos
and to hold events so
that other people who
are out there wondering, is
Google a place that I can
aspire to, or is the
Department of Labor
a place I can aspire to?
Sandra Day O'Connor once said
in a very important opinion
on affirmative action,
people across the country
need to see that
pathways to leadership
are visibly
available, and if they
don't see people
who look like them,
then those pathways
don't look very visible.
So I think months like
this are pretty important.
DANIEL ALEGRE: And I agree.
We had every Thursday,
it's called TGIF, thank god
it's, I guess it should
be called Thursday,
but Thank Good it's Friday.
THOMAS PEREZ: To get--
DANIEL ALEGRE: To get to Friday,
a celebration of Hispanics
at Google.
And one of the things,
the feedback that we
got from Googlers
all around actually
was great to even
just talk about it,
because it gave
Hispanics within Google
a feeling that
they could belong,
and they could actually
be part of a community.
How important is that to you
in your role as a Hispanic,
as a very prominent Hispanic
in the Obama administration?
Does that carry a lot of
burden for you as a role model?
How does that impact you?
THOMAS PEREZ: I don't see
it as a burden at all.
I see it as a privilege
and a responsibility.
So this Thursday, when
we're doing this event
at the Department
of Labor, we're
going to have roughly 40
students from my son's
high school.
They're all Latino
students, and they're all
living in some economically
challenging circumstances.
And one of the
things I've observed
in the course of the
work that I've done
is that a lot of
people who haven't
had the good fortune that
I've had, one of the things
that they lack is mentors.
Some people call
it social capital.
People older than 50
call it a Rolodex.
People like you all don't
know what a Rolodex is.
And if you want to be a
nurse, but you've never
met someone who's a nurse, it's
hard to carry that aspiration.
And so we're bringing
these students
so that they can see what
the Department of Labor
is, so that they can meet
an iconic figure like Artie.
And then afterward,
we can talk about some
of the other
opportunities that exist.
For instance, we were on the job
corps, which the job corps is--
we just celebrated our 50th
anniversary a couple of years
ago.
It's a great
society program that
has helped literally tens
of thousands of people,
whose life path was
not linear, but who
have as much talent as folks
who follow the linear path.
It helped them to get
access to opportunity.
And so the more you can do that,
then the greater the likelihood
that folks who have talent
can harness that talent.
DANIEL ALEGRE: And again,
any questions, please
line up at the microphone.
I'm curious in your view,
how important is technology
for Hispanics in the US?
You talked about education and
getting access to education.
Where does technology
fit into all of it?
THOMAS PEREZ: Oh, enormous.
I mean we were just talking,
and I recall one of the slides
said that Latinos are
something like three times
more likely to
have a smartphone.
Is that the right data point?
And I see that.
I mean we have 5.9 million
job openings right now
across America,
which is the highest
number we've had since we've
been keeping this data series.
And about 1/10 of those job
openings are in the IT space.
And a substantial
subset of those
don't require a college degree,
so when I talk about IT,
sometimes people's first
reaction is, well, I
don't have time to get
a Ph.D. And the response
is, you don't need a Ph.D.
And we've made a
lot of investments
and formed a lot of partnerships
with public school systems
to translate that fluency
that a lot of young people,
including but not
limited to young Latinos,
have with their gadgets,
and translate that
into a pipeline to
a middle class job.
And so it's really
exciting to go and see
these coding camps and other
things that are available.
So I mean technology, and I
wouldn't limit it to Latinos.
I mean if you're not
tech savvy, you're
just not going to succeed
in a 21st century economy.
And we still have
this digital divide,
and so we have more work
to do in that space.
DANIEL ALEGRE: And I agree.
I think the incredible access
to mobile and mobile telephony
and mobile phones and
getting cheaper and cheaper
is really just opening up the
entire world of information
and access to
education to anybody.
I'll ask the first question.
You mind introducing yourself?
AUDIENCE: My question's
actually really into--
DANIEL ALEGRE: Do you mind
introducing yourself, please?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
my name is Jorge,
and my question is related
to the automation of jobs
in America.
Specifically, I was
looking at an article
on Planet Money on NPR that was
published last year that said
that the most common job across
most states was truck driving,
and with the advent of
self-driving cars, which Google
is also developing here,
probably all those jobs
are going to be automated.
So we're going to have
self-driving trucks,
and then we also have the
CEO of Carl's Jr. saying
that he's going to replace a
lot of the jobs in Carl's Jr.
restaurants with automated
robots or machines.
And for example, my own dad
just lost his job recently
and was working as an Uber
driver, which is probably
also going to be a job that's
going to get automated away
with Uber testing
out self-driving cars
in Pittsburgh.
So how is Labor
Department looking
at this automation of
jobs and planning ahead
to make sure that
a lot of people
aren't left out in
the cold when we
have structural changes
in the labor laws?
THOMAS PEREZ: Well,
it's a great question,
and as someone who grew
up in Buffalo, New York,
I have firsthand
knowledge of what happens
when you're not prepared.
I was a kid when my
father passed away,
and my surrogate father had the
ninth or 10th grade education.
He was the wisest person
I met, and I've actually
grown to wonder whether
there's an inverse correlation
between the number
of years you have
of education and your wisdom.
But that's an aside.
And he was a teamster,
and he lost his job
when the economy
tanked in Buffalo.
And because he had
a lot of talent,
but he never had access
to opportunity to upskill.
So he ended up pumping gas,
working as a security guard,
doing anything to
make ends meet.
And so what I learned from
that very personal message
of watching them suffer
and lose their home
and lose their dignity
was that we always
have to be one step ahead.
This is not the first time
in our nation's history
that the very important question
you asked has been asked.
And the key is not only to
provide people with the skills
to succeed today, but
with the core competencies
to thrive tomorrow so
that today it's the cloud.
In a few years, the cloud
will become the abacus.
And so you want to equip
people with the fluency
to do IT work at the Department
of Labor today with the cloud,
but also with that competency
to keep moving forward.
Learning is lifelong, and
the Republic Steel plant,
which employed 20,000 people
when I was a kid in Buffalo,
is being replaced by the largest
solar panel manufacturing
facility in the Western
hemisphere, a Solar City plant.
And that will
probably employ 4,000,
something like that, a fraction
of what it used to employ.
And we've got to
make sure, and you'll
see tablets, not
folks running around
with hammers, because that's
the world in which we live.
And so I think the key
there is to make sure
that we are always equipped
with the skills that
will enable us to thrive.
And for some people,
thriving will
mean entering a new line
of work, a steel worker
that we helped to
retrain and retool,
so now he's in
advanced manufacturing.
And so today's
drivers, I still think
they have a good glide
path ahead of them
for a number of years to
come, but we will always
make sure they're
prepared for whatever
happens in the next iteration
of technological advance.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Good afternoon,
Secretary Perez.
This is Javier Gonzales.
I just wanted to ask you, what
are some of the key moments
with President Barack Obama
that you've had that you'll be
sharing in your
memoir once you're--
THOMAS PEREZ:
Well, I don't think
I can get enough people
to read my memoir,
so my memoir is going
to stick in my head.
It's incredible--
it's always helpful--
just like this is sort
of a basic moment,
and I don't think
it's groundbreaking.
It's always nice when
you have the smartest
person in the room on
your side, because we've
been in a lot of
tense situations,
and his command of the
issues is remarkable.
And when I think about
my memories with him,
I think about really,
I think the courage
that he's had to
do things that have
people, a lot of naysayers.
History will judge the
Affordable Care Act as one
of the most important
additions to our social safety
net in our nation's
history, but we
have a number of
challenges now that
are borne in no small
measure from the fact
that there has been a
relentless campaign of people
to make it fail,
and governors who
are leaving billions
of dollars on the table
so that they don't give
Barack Obama a victory,
even though they're hurting
literally tens of thousands,
if not more of
their constituents.
So I guess number
one is just watching
him understand that
I don't care as much
about how I'm judged tomorrow.
I will look at this through
a long term prism of history.
And I've seen that in the ACA.
I've seen it in some work we
did enacting an overtime rule.
I've seen it in work
we've done to make sure
that people who
save for retirement
have access to advice that's
in their best interest.
We take a lot of heat
when you do those things,
but frankly, I think every
day he's motivated as I am by,
how can I strengthen and grow
the middle class in America?
And I am absolutely-- he
has a lot more gray hair
than he had eight years ago.
I'm jealous,
because he has hair.
So that's for me
what I will remember
is those individual examples
of when we did the right thing.
And I can go home to
my kid and say, hey,
we helped 2 million home
health workers today
get access to a decent
standard of living
because of a final
rule we put in place.
That's kind of cool.
And it wouldn't
happen but for him.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming
in and taking our questions
today, Secretary Perez.
So my name is Benjamin Clark.
For obvious reasons, much of
the focus on the labor market
is on helping the
unemployed find jobs.
However, it is also important
to help those currently employed
who want a better job find it.
This includes those
working part time,
but want full time work, those
working in positions which
don't utilize their
training or education,
and those simply looking
for a higher paid job.
Surfing LinkedIn and
other job aggregator sites
and submitting dozens of resumes
isn't a great or scalable
approach, especially
with 10 million employers
in the United States today.
So what changes can be made
to increase labor market
efficiency for these
workers, and what
role is there for government
and technology in doing so?
THOMAS PEREZ: That's
a great question,
and about two
years ago, Congress
in one of the
regrettably few pieces
of impactful
bipartisan legislation
passed a bill called
the Workforce Innovation
and Opportunity Act.
And it was a
modernization of the rules
of engagement for our
public workforce system.
We have 2,500 American job
centers around the country.
So if you lose your
job or you have a job,
and you want to
get a better job,
you can go to an American
Job Center free of cost,
and we help literally
millions of people.
These American Job
Centers were basically
the nation's emergency room
during the Great Recession.
And what the Workforce
Innovation and Opportunity
Act has done is,
among other things,
it has placed a focus on
not only folks who are out
of a job who want
a job, but folks
who are looking for incumbent
worker opportunities.
So you're in the
job, but you want
the skills for a better job.
So a lot of the funding
streams that are
coming through the Workforce
Innovation and Opportunity Act,
before they were
focused more on someone
who's looking for a job.
Now there's still
a focus on that,
but there's a lot
more flexibility.
So in some markets,
really the issue
is not getting people
in, because unemployment
is really low.
But it is upskilling
people, because there's
a skills mismatch.
There's a lot of
demand in one area,
but we don't have the pipeline.
So the Workforce Innovation
and Opportunity Act I think
is a real key indicator.
I'm actually going to
Glassdoor tomorrow,
and part of what we're
going to discuss there
is really about your question,
because the more information
people have, the
more power they have.
And I've really appreciated not
only data we get through you,
but things that we've been
doing with Glassdoor to make
the process more transparent.
There's still too much
opaqueness to the job search
process, and you still are
flying a little bit blind.
You go into
somewhere, and we need
to do more than just
Yelp for jobseekers.
We need to, I think,
get more information,
and Glassdoor-- we have
data that we collect.
Glassdoor is a great
data aggregator,
and so we're trying to figure
out what else we can do,
because the market is shifting
from what it was before.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Secretary Perez.
Bienvenido a Google.
THOMAS PEREZ: Gracias.
AUDIENCE: My name is Alberto,
and I'm an engineer here
at Google.
My question is,
lately there's been
a lot of focus and narrative
around bringing jobs back,
specifically manufacturing jobs.
So given that the US
economy is actually
greatly services-based, why
is the focus and the narrative
around manufacturing jobs?
Shouldn't it be around services?
And if so, what
are the initiatives
that the administration is
doing to amplify and increase
the availability of jobs in
the service industry or sector?
THOMAS PEREZ: Well, actually,
it's not an either/or.
And when you look
at what we're doing,
it's really both and then some.
The emphasis on manufacturing
is a function of the fact
that manufacturing has great
multiplier opportunities.
When you create a manufacturing
job, I own a Ford Escape,
and it was built in
Louisville, Kentucky.
And now that they were 800
employees in the depths
of the Great Recession.
They're up to over 4,000
now, and that doesn't
include their supply chain.
And so when you create
good manufacturing jobs,
you're able to have that very
remarkable multiplier effect,
and also give opportunity--
in relationship
to another question,
folks who've
lost their job at
the steel mill,
they're incredibly
capable of working
in an advanced
manufacturing context.
And what we're seeing
from our outreach
to businesses is that the
reason why businesses are
bullish about making things
in America is number one,
we are the best consumer
in the world right now,
and our economy is better
than basically everybody else.
And number two, there's IT
stability in the United States.
You make things
in China, and you
employ a lot of lawyers who
are dealing with IT issues
and intellectual property
issues of that nature.
And I talk to a lot
of businesses, who
talk a lot about cube footage.
So if you're making
big things overseas,
it costs a lot to
ship them home.
I spent a lot of time here
during the ports dispute that
really tied up the
West Coast port system,
and the president sent me
here to try to resolve that.
And I learned a lot about
why more and more folks who
make things overseas are
thinking about making them here
at home.
And you look at the
Trans-Pacific Partnership,
which is one of the
trade agreements
that has been the focus of a
lot of discussion and debate,
and trade agreements
always are the focus
of discussion and debate.
And there are entire chapters
on the services industry,
because there's a recognition
that in our global economy,
we don't simply make products
like airplanes for exports.
The service sector
is a remarkable set
of opportunities, of which
you've already availed yourself
of.
But as the president
has outlined,
a properly done trade
agreement can even
open up even more doors.
So we're doing both and then
some is, I think, the upshot.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for joining
us today, Secretary Perez.
My name Ana Dias Hernandez.
I work at Udacity, which is
an online education company.
And I work on workforce
development partnerships, as
well as employer partnerships.
So I help our students get jobs
after they take our courses.
And so my question
is really aligned
on so a part of our strategy
is that we work with companies
to create courses that are
relevant for the workforce
so that people can take
the course and get a job.
And sometimes those companies
even help fund scholarships
so that the students out there
in the workforce can take them
and then aspire to get
a job in that sector.
And so my question
to you would be,
where do you think
companies could take
some leadership around
funding courses,
where there's a current
market gap, where there aren't
enough people trained
to do something,
and that could really
be thinking, one, two,
five years ahead and start
training people right away?
THOMAS PEREZ: We're
starting to see, I think,
a very promising
evolution in that space.
I mean we do a lot of
work in this space.
We have an entire office
of workforce development
that is all about the work
that you're describing.
And the old model
of HR I describe
as the cannibalism model of HR.
You've got talent here, so
I'll cherry pick your talent,
and then you cherry pick my
talent, and that's zero sum HR.
What we're seeing now in
today's paradigm, which
is very exciting, is that
sectors are coming together
recognizing that we've
got to grow the pie.
We've got to create a
virtuous cycle, and the way we
do that is through aggregating
our collective wisdom,
coming together around
working with people who train,
so community colleges
and colleges.
And you go to-- I spent a lot
of time with community colleges.
And the reason why they're
having so much success
is because they have
business representation
in their department.
So when you're taking a course,
you're getting a degree,
you're getting a certificate,
that business has a lot more
confidence that that degree
has the requisite competencies
to thrive in my company,
because I helped create it.
And I've talked to a lot
of business owners, who
are kind of a little bit ripped,
frankly, at four-year higher
ed, because I'm getting these
people who have a computer
science degree.
But then they come in,
and they don't really
have a lot of the basics.
I've heard this in the sciences.
People who have a
degree, but they
don't know how to work in
a lab, because they never
had the practical experience.
So I think what we're
seeing now through what
we call sector strategies,
where we get an IT sector,
and we understand, what are
your needs projected forward,
and how do we do a better job
of working with our institutions
so that they are producing that
pipeline of folks that don't
simply have the degree, but they
have the core competencies that
come with that degree
that are necessary?
And that's, to me, what's
exciting about today's-- I call
it the-- we're constructing
a skill superhighway.
And we need new and
different on ramps.
We're doing a lot in the
world of apprenticeship.
When you think of
an apprentice, you
think of a plumber
and a carpenter.
An apprenticeship has
obvious application there,
but if you go to Europe,
which I have done,
you will see 18 and
19-year-olds and 16
and 17-year-old
apprentices, who are
going to be tomorrow's CEOs.
The most recent CEO of Zurich
Insurance, a Fortune 500
company, started out
as an apprentice.
So we're trying to build these
new on ramps and off ramps that
address exactly
what you're doing,
because the good news--
we have a great problem,
but it is a problem, which is
that businesses are bullish.
They want to grow
their business.
And we've got to make sure
that the pipeline of folks,
especially the pipeline
living in communities that
have been historically
underserved,
is ready for that task.
I'm confident we
can do it, but it
does take that much more
collaboration at scale.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you, Secretary
Perez for coming.
My name is David Moulton.
Despite the fact
that people have
been talking about the
gender wage gap for decades,
women are still
making less money
for doing equivalent jobs.
So what do you think are
the kind of best ways
that we as a country
can move forward
to get to a point, where women
are making the same money
for doing the same things?
THOMAS PEREZ: That's
a great question.
I'm looking at your
t-shirt, and I'm
reflecting on a visit I
made to one of my friends
in college to
Princeton, and it was
the first time I had seen an
orange squirrel in my life.
So I wanted to comment
on your t-shirt.
AUDIENCE: A black one.
THOMAS PEREZ: But I digress.
I mean there's no one
quick answer to that.
But one thing we've
been doing lately,
and we were having this
conversation today,
is pay transparency.
When Lilly Ledbetter-- the first
law that the president signed
was the Lilly
Ledbetter Fair Pay Act.
And she was working
at her job in Alabama,
and doing identical work to
men, making less than them,
and the way she found
out was because someone
slipped her an anonymous note.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Happened to my mother.
THOMAS PEREZ: You know,
you all understand
the importance of data,
and data shouldn't just
be collected and hidden.
Data should be collected
and made available.
So that's one thing.
Another thing we
need to do is to make
sure we have 21st century paid
leave and childcare policies.
If you compare labor
force participation
of women in the US and
Canada in the year 2000,
it was virtually identical.
You look now.
Canada is about eight
points higher than we are,
because they've invested in
paid leave and childcare.
And so if we'd have
kept pace, we'd
have 5 and 1/2 million more
women in the workplace,
5 and 1/2 million more
women contributing
to the social security trust
fund, the Medicare trust fund,
and contributing to making,
whether it's the Silicon
Valley, Wall Street, or Main
Street look more like America.
I think those two issues
are absolutely huge.
And so when you leave the
market, you end up coming back,
and you've fallen behind.
And so then you see
these gaps exacerbated.
And then finally, you've
got to enforce the laws,
because I've seen some textbook
examples of nuts and bolts
discrimination.
And so I'm heartened by the fact
that more and more employers
are understanding, and we're
seeing a lot more leadership
on this issue, because we're
leaving too much talent
on the sideline with this.
And it just is not right.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Julissa
Ramirez, and I
am a Dominicana from New York.
So happy to have you here.
My question is, as
you know, the number
of STEM jobs, a very
small percentage of those
are held by Latinos.
What is your department
doing to increase
the number of Latinas and
Latinos in STEM jobs in the US?
THOMAS PEREZ: Well, that's an
all hands on deck enterprise
across the
administration working
with the Department of Energy,
the Department of Education.
I was convening earlier today
with the California Endowment
talking about how we increased
the pipeline of minority
students in the
health professions.
That's a public
health challenge,
because there's too many
under-served communities.
And there's a
robust body of data
showing that health
care providers of color
are more likely to serve
communities of color.
And so that's why
it starts at pre-K.
One of the reasons the
president has supported
dramatic investments
in early childhood
is because the research
is overwhelming.
All too many people, by the
time they're three years old,
because of
opportunity gaps, they
have not heard nearly
the number of words
that other folks have heard.
And so you start out when
you're three years old,
and you're already up
against the eight ball.
So your question calls for,
I think, a very holistic set
of investments starting
from pre-K, making sure
that pipeline-- the
pipeline springs leaks
in so many different places.
We still have too many
schools that are not
where they need to be.
And we still have
too many young kids
of color, who
don't have mentors.
And there's a lot
of evidence showing
that the absence of mentors is
a big deal for folks as well.
So there's really a soup to
nuts, cradle to grave approach
that we have to take
to this, because we've
got a lot more work to do.
And it's a public health
imperative in the health
professions context.
It's an economic
imperative for all of us,
and frankly, it's
a moral imperative.
Last question.
DANIEL ALEGRE: Last
question, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Last question.
OK.
Secretary Perez,
thank you for being
here with us this afternoon.
My name is Michael
Wooley-Ousdahl.
I'm on Google's
transportation team.
Climate change is
really important to me
and being energy independent.
I'm curious your
thoughts on coal country.
My great-grandfather was a
coal miner in Pennsylvania.
You heard this at
the debate yesterday.
This ongoing kind of
disconnect with the narrative
of folks that are
in coal country
that their livelihood is
based on fossil fuels,
and our need to become
energy independent
and invest in clean energy.
And there seems
to be a disconnect
in that narrative with
the Democratic Party
and folks in coal country and
whose livelihood is based on,
their labor pool is based
on fossil fuels and coal.
How do you hope the future
administration going forward,
whoever's elected, a
Democrat or a Republican,
how do you hope they approach
that narrative of investing
in clean energy and
climate change with this
disconnect with folks
that livelihoods are
based on fossil fuels and coal?
THOMAS PEREZ: Well, I hope we
can have honest dialogue that
is evidence-based.
When I hear about
the war on coal,
one of the biggest forces that
has created a challenge in coal
country is natural gas.
But that's not
what is discussed.
One of my favorite visits
in this job-- and it
really goes to the
heart of your question--
I was in coal country
Kentucky, Pipeville.
And there was a
company that we helped
to seed called Bitsource.
And I went to a
training program.
There were about
15 people there,
and what they all had
in common is that they
were generational coal miners.
And as a guy who
grew up in Buffalo,
I understand Buffalo's
manufacturing base wasn't
simply a pipeline for jobs.
It was part of our identity.
And when you have
generational coal miners,
and you say, well,
sorry, market forces
are working against
you, that's not simply
an economic statement.
You're really going
at people's identity.
But we have realities,
and in a lot
of the places in Kentucky
and West Virginia,
the cost of extraction
has become very expensive,
because they've mined out all
the easy to mine out stuff.
And given our environmental
necessities, et cetera,
these folks were
learning how to code.
And the motto of Bitsource
was from coal to code.
And I remember vividly one
of the guys, who said to me,
my company called me
last week to offer me
a job back at the
mine, and I said no,
because I feel like I have
more of a future here.
Another guy said-- he had a
screenshot of his newborn,
and he said, when my
son gets to be 10 or 12,
and he says, Daddy,
I can't do this.
I got a hard assignment school.
I'm going to tell him, I
got out of the coal mine,
because I did that.
I lost my job.
Your grandfather had that job.
Your great-grandfather
had that job.
And I lost my job, and I thought
I couldn't do anything else.
I'd never turned a computer on
in my life, and now I'm coding.
You can do anything, son.
That's what he's going
to say to his son.
And if there's one thing
I've learned in this job,
it is how resilient people
are, because one constant
that my father always
taught me is change.
We are not a static country.
Today there are
tens of thousands
of good middle class
jobs for truck drivers.
I don't know where that will be,
that world in 20 or 30 years.
If you look at the studies,
sometimes the predictions
of the impact of automation
prove not exactly
to bear out as they might.
But you always got
to prepare for it.
And the thing that we have
going for us as a nation
is that we've got a
resilient group of folks,
and those folks in coal
country, they're now coding.
And so what we are doing
as an administration, what
we need to continue to do is
to make sure we say to folks,
honestly, you know what?
Our goal here is to make sure
that you can punch your ticket
to the middle class.
I can't look you
in the eye and say
it's going to be in a coal mine,
because there's a lot of stuff
happening out there.
But what I can do is look
you in the eye and say,
we're going to do
everything in our power
to make sure that you have those
core competencies to thrive,
and continue to punch your
ticket to the middle class.
So it could be the
coders, or it can
be the guy who came
to one of our meetings
at the White House, drove
all night with his wife,
generational coal
miner, who's now an EMT.
And again, resilient.
This is a resilient workforce.
This is a resilient country.
And when I hear folks
bad mouth this country
and say the gloom
and doom stuff,
you just haven't
made house calls,
because I've met folks who
have been down on their luck
through no fault of their own.
And what always amazes me
is that stick-to-itiveness
that they have.
And we have to be part
of the connective tissue.
That's why I love my job,
because part of what we do
is we're match.com.
We help connect
them to-- it might
be a job in the same
industry, or it might
be a totally different job.
The good news is that employers
tell me everywhere I go,
I'm bullish about the future.
I want to grow my business.
And what I need most, Tom, is
I need that skilled workforce,
so I can continue to grow.
I'm chronically optimistic
as a result of all
of these conversations,
and we've
been able to stay
at 5% unemployment.
And you look at the
rest of the world
where they're at, because
we've got this resilient
workforce, resilient
business community,
and some great partnerships.
Thank you for your question.
It's a great way to
end this conversation.
[APPLAUSE]
DANIEL ALEGRE: The energy with
which the secretary speaks
is just infectious.
I feel like I should go
and learn coding right now.
I should.
THOMAS PEREZ: Me too.
DANIEL ALEGRE: But I think
your example of you owning
a Ford and the
trickle effect that it
has of being able to manufacture
here in the United States
I think is also an example
of you as a Hispanic leader,
the fact that you've
made it as far as you had
in your career and
the impact you've
had not only to your
family, your community,
but everyone who looks
up to you I think
is an inspiration
for many Hispanics
all in the United States
and around the world.
So on behalf of Google,
on behalf of Hola,
thank you for coming.
THOMAS PEREZ: Thank you.
Muchas gracias.
DANIEL ALEGRE: And best of
luck in this next few months,
and obviously, in
2017 going forward.
[APPLAUSE]
Muchas gracias.